بالتنويه لهذا الخبر العاجل نقلا عن مراسل
الجزيره دوي انفجار في الجهه الشماليه من
العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء اذا دوي انفجار في
الجهه الشماليه من العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء
في انتظار المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذا
الخبر وسنتناول
حال
ورودها ايضا نبقى في الاخبار العاجله قناه
المسيره التابعه للحوثيين تقول ان العدو
الامريكي البريط
يستهدف العاصمه صنعاء بعدد من الغارات اذا
نقلا عن قناه المسيره التابعه للحوثيين
تقول ان العدو الامريكيه والبريطانيه كما
تصفه يستهدف العاصمه صنعاء بعدد من
الغارات اذا مراسل الجزيره قبل ذلك
قد نقل لنا بان هناك دوي انفجار في الجهه
الشماليه من العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء وقناه
المسيره التابعه للحوثيين تقول ان العدو
الامريكي البريطانيه يصدف العاصمه صنعاء
بعدد من الغارات ياتي هذا في
سياق واضح يتعلق ب ما يقوم به الجانب
الامريكي والبريطاني من استهداف لبعض
المناطق كما يقول تهدف الى القضاء على
قدره الحوثيين في استهداف السفن المتجهه
الى اسرائيل او السفن
الاسرائيليه في باب المندب خليج عدن
والبحر الاحمر و